I used to do a lot of athletics in high
school but I was like 10 years ago
I exercise a lot because I eat a lot and
so I exercise so I can eat whatever I
want I am doing Crossfit about five to
six times a week and weightlifting one
time I run about two miles once a week
maybe twice a week I don't think I'm
quite as fit as an FBI agent I'm afraid
of throwing up on camera I'd like to
pass what I'd like to be top of the
class I want to beat all these dudes to
attain a passing score on the physical
fitness test you must earn at least one
point in each four events and at least a
cumulative score of 12 points do we have
to fight a criminal while we do this too
[Music]
I think I was like 34 30 and then the
second half I slowed down so that sucked
trying to do a sit-up a second but not
quite so I'm a failure
puking might actually happen I had good
momentum the top and then like the last
20 seconds my stomach just wanted to eat
I thought halfway through oh yeah I'm
just running and I'm like oh if this was
a serious situation I better turn on the
Jets my legs are on fire I was just
imagining that he was a murderer I don't
like that the fastest ever run oh my I
can't believe it was five-second talk oh
I feel
my goal is 60 and after that I was like
you Matt your goal you're done I got 40
which is respectable hung up on the
failure success my longer limbs I'd be
killing it right now you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whole body hurts it's all fire and sweat
I stopped probably twice I started
seeing stars and didn't want to push it
so hard that I might pass out
I got 11 minutes and 6 seconds which
actually was faster than I expected
because I was kind of gassed out at the
end of this I came in at 1310 which just
qualifies me because I got zero points
I'm really glad to physically be able to
get them to FBI I'm surprised that I was
able to pass the test I got 13 points
but I fail I'm pretty stoked that I was
able to pass half of the test no I think
I would take my own physical fitness
more seriously I mean this was fun I
feel like I got a good workout and I
guess I'll continue to not have a gym
membership because it seems like it's
working out for me I'm gonna start
challenging myself to set better goals
and expectations meet and surpass those
so thanks FBI you know I got to work on
my cardio got to work on my speed you
know I feel like I could get there if
anybody from the FBI is watching I've
never done drugs and I'm available to be
higher
[Music]